Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American science fiction
comedy family film called “Honey, I Blew
Up the Kid”. Watch out and take care!
The movie centers around a family of five,
the Szalinski family. The father, Wayne, is an
inventor who invents household things that helps
his family work efficiently. In the opening scene,
we see an automated mailbox that receives the
daily newspaper. The family dog runs to the box
every morning and picks a bone attached to it.
Because of it, the newspaper drops below and he
brings it back to his master. Even the neighbors
are amazed by the innovation. Other than that,
Wayne has made a helmet for himself that helps
him shave, a sound system that helps his wife
call the children when breakfast is ready,
and many other inventions similar to them.
One day, Wayne’s wife Diane is flying to
another state to see off her eldest daughter Amy
to college. She will be gone for a few days
and wants her husband to take good care of
their middle child, Nick, and the youngest Adam.
After she leaves, Wayne rushes to his job and is
late as usual. He works at Sterling Labs of
innovation. His project partner Dr. Charles
is not fond of Wayne because he is better than
him. Hence, the doctor tries to exclude Wayne
from the experiments as much as possible. A few
years ago, Wayne developed a prototype that could
shrink people and objects into a minuscule size.
Currently, the lab is trying to develop a device
that does the opposite. Dr. Charles tests the
prototype by using it on a crystal. At first,
the crystal grows as expected, but right when the
team thinks the experiment worked, it wiggles and
explodes all over Dr. Charles’s face.
He is disappointed, to say the least. He
is being pressured by the company’s president and
the US government to complete the prototype soon.
Wayne has innovative ideas that could help them
but Dr. Charles refuses to listen to him. At home,
chaos ensues because of Diane's absence. The guys
burn food in the microwave every time they use it.
Diane calls them and asks them to heat the chicken
that she made before leaving. With burnt chicken
in front of him, Wayne lies to her that it tastes
delicious. At last, they have to settle with
peanut butter and toast for dinner.
After that, Wayne tucks Adam to sleep
and sings him a lullaby along with his favorite
toy big bunny. While he is at it, he suddenly gets
the idea of why the crystal exploded that day at
work. He calls Dr. Charles and explains his theory
but the man dismisses him. He thinks that Wayne is
an idiot, incapable of such advanced inventions.
The following day is the weekend but Wayne comes
to work along with his kids. He has planned to
make the required changes in the prototype without
informing Dr. Charles. The lab guard sees him go
inside without registering his name and calls
Dr. Charles to inform him. In the meantime, Wayne
fixes the problem and decides to use the prototype
on Adam’s toy, Big Bunny. As the countdown starts,
Adam goes to the platform to get his toy and is
hit with the light wave coming from the prototype.
When everything goes silent, Wayne sees that his
idea didn’t work and returns home with the kids,
unaware that his son was blasted with
a ray of radiation. As they leave,
the guard comments that Adam has grown
bigger, but no one thinks much of it.
On their way back home, Nick asks Wayne why he
needs Dr. Charles’s permission to work on his
own invention. It turns out the idea and initial
plan was Wayne’s but since his partner Dr. Charles
doesn’t like him, he has taken over the project.
At home, Wayne calls Nick’s crush Mandy to come
and babysit Adam. He and Nick want to go out to
the movies for father-son time. When Adam is alone
in the kitchen, he is exposed to electrical waves
from the microwave oven. This causes him to grow
over seven feet tall because of the radiation he
received earlier. When his father and brother see
him, they are beyond surprised. They soon
realize that Adam was exposed to radiation
from the prototype. They immediately decide
to return to the lab and reverse the process.
To avoid walking in with a seven feet baby,
they disguise Adam to the best of his abilities.
However, they are stopped by Dr. Charles who
kicks Wayne out of the project. It turns out
that because of the experiment Wayne had conducted
earlier, a power surge occurred which deleted all
the information about the experiment.
Disheartened, Wayne returns home, hoping to
get Adam back to normal before Diane gets back.
But his plan fails when he sees her waiting for
them with Big Bunny who has grown big like Adam.
At first, they try to run away so she won’t see
the grown baby. But knowing that they cannot
hide for long, Wayne comes clean to his wife.
When she gets a look at Adam, she passes
out in shock. As Wayne wakes her up,
Nick tries to get Adam to sit down. The baby plays
around and destroys half the things in the house.
When he is locked in his room, he opens the
entire door and brings it outside. By now,
the neighbors have gathered outside Szalinski's
residence because of all the noise. After running
around for almost an hour trying to catch him,
they finally calm him down and put him into a
bigger playpen. Wayne gets a chance to think of
the reason the kid grew when he was brought home
and not when he was hit with radiation. Although
he doesn’t get the answers, he remembers that his
old prototype could shrink people down. The device
is currently stored in the Sterling warehouse.
If they can bring it back, there is a chance
Adam will be brought back to his normal size.
Wayne then makes Adam take a nap. He and
Diane go to retrieve the first prototype
while Nick takes the responsibility to keep
an eye on Adam. After the parents leave,
Mandy arrives at the house to babysit. Nick tries
sending her away but she sees Adam and freaks out.
With no way out, he ties her to a chair and gags
her so she wouldn’t run away or tell anyone. In
the meantime, the parents arrive at the warehouse
that has hundreds of crates. They look around and
finally find the prototype they are looking
for. Back in the house, Nick tries explaining
everything to Mandy. Adam is watching the TV
in the other room. The radiation from the TV
makes him get even taller. He runs away from the
house. Nick and Mandy run outside to look for him
while Adam wreaks havoc in the neighborhood. He is
sitting in the middle of the street with his bunny
while a crowd watches. Dr. Chrales also sees
this and realizes why Wayne was in the lab
on the weekend. Wayne and Diane are on their way
back home. Diane is driving while Wayne is fixing
his old prototype in the back of the car.
They are followed by two policemen for speeding.
Wayne uses the prototype on them and shrinks the
two. Before escaping, he turns them back to their
normal size, leaving them amazed. Dr. Charles
takes the responsibility to handle the situation
with Adam. He wants to use the chaos that Adam
has caused to drive the president against Wayne.
He has already sent Adam to the lab to get tested
when his parents return. On their way to the lab,
Adam gets struck with a bigger wave of radiation
because of the electric cables. This grows his
size even more and he escapes from the van.
The president of Sterling lab, Clifford,
finally arrives at the Szalinski residence. Dr.
Chrales tells him that everything was Wayne’s
fault but the president is impressed by Wayne
for doing what the other scientists couldn’t.
He fires Dr. Charles for not being a team worker
and helps Wayne. A policeman informs them of
Adam’s escape and they run to save him. Meanwhile,
Dr. Charles calls a board member of Sterling's lab
named Terence who agrees to help him get his
position back. On their way to get Adam, Clifford
and Wayne come to realize that he is growing in
size because of electromagnetic flux. Since Adam
is making his way to Las Vegas, he is going to
grow even bigger because of the neon signs.
Dr. Charles meets Terence who brings
him back to the team using his authority
as the board member. Dr. Charles wants
to use the military to stop the havoc.
Everyone finally makes it to the highway that
Adam is on. They are shocked to see that he has
grown into a giant. For the shrinking prototype to
work, the kid has to hold still for twelve seconds
which the parents think is impossible. He comes
closer to them, revealing that Nick and Mandy are
inside his pockets. Just then, Wayne comes up with
an idea. He calls the police to bring Big Bunny
to Adam. A helicopter brings the toy to the kid
as Wayne sings a lullaby. The plan works and Adam
is about to sleep when Wayne mentions he has to
take a nap. Adam, who always hated the word nap,
refuses to sleep after that. Then, he walks to
Las Vegas, threatening to destroy everything
on his way. Somewhere else, Dr. Charles gets
ready with a tranquilizer gun and a helicopter
to sedate the kid, even though it means severe
health risks. Adam finally reaches the city and
starts running around the streets. A crowd of
people gathers to see him, some of them running
away to save their lives. The street lights and
signs amuse him, making him even more frantic.
When he bends down, Mandy and Nick manage to climb
down to a yellow car. But Adam picks it up and
swings it in the air to play with it. He places
them on a billboard where they hang dangerously.
As the crowd watches, holding its breath,
he finally puts the car inside his pockets,
not harming his brother and Mandy in any way.
Following that, Wayne gets another one of his
great ideas. He knows that Adam likes ice
cream more than anything in his life. Hence,
he plans to lure him into a secluded highway
using an ice cream truck. The plan works and
Adam chases behind the truck. However, he
closes on it quickly and the driver has to
stop to save his life. Then, Dr. Charles arrives
at the scene on a helicopter with a tranquilizer
gun. He misses the first shot while the second
one lands on a guitar the kid is holding.
It hurts Adam and he begins to cry. At last,
Diane volunteers to be shot by the prototype
so she can be bigger than Adam and can hold
him down. After being hit by the radiation,
she grows even taller than the skyscrapers.
Adam sees her and stops crying. As the two hug,
Wayne shoots them with his first prototype and
turns them back into their normal sizes. After
everything calms down, Diane punches Dr. Charles
in the face for trying to hurt her son.
All of a sudden, they remember that
Nick and Mandy were in Adam’s pocket.
Meaning that they might have turned minuscule
because of the prototype. They use their dog to
look for them. It turns out that they are stuck in
a tiny car. Mandy compliments Nick saying that he
is different from most guys she meets. She leans
on his shoulders, making him blush. Wayne soon
finds him and the story ends happily.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.